[Music]
oh that's my gain there's my gain I
found my
gain okay I don't think I need to turn
it up hello and welcome back to the pill
pod pill pod
145 now we got a lot of news going on
I'd love to get Diego's takes on the
news but
that would leave us uh less time to deal
with something that
is I don't know how arguably worse than
genocide which is holy [__] which is
metamodernism if you are one of the
dozen or so people who have DMD me on
the various channels asking me to cover
metamodernism uh this will be it oh have
you received a lot of these requests
yeah I have it's uh it's a trending
internet thing I don't think it's very
widely trending like I said it's only a
dozen anyway it's me pills and it's Eric
hello and we have with us Diego who
invited us to read this book hello guys
so it's it's I am the one to blame yeah
we finally caved in when Diego made the
request I was one of the 12 people that
made a request so H
me one of the wise men I'm actually very
interested in your take on this to be
honest with you like since you guys are
the academics you guys know what you're
talking about I was just the the Curious
sophist reading random stuff I found on
the web I'm actually very very
interested into this well let's not say
that we know what we're talking about um
I feel like I do and feelings are all
that matter in
postmodernism but Diego can you tell can
you explain uh kind of what you got out
of this and why you wanted us to read it
I mean yeah well you first you you said
you found it when you were just
searching for things to read on the
internet so how did you stumble across
this oh so the way The Story Goes how I
got in touch with this with this line of
thought let's say metamodernism it was
via two friends of mine that were
actually philosophers that I actually
respect and and I normally take advice
from them quite often one of them is
Ernesto Castro the guy's a PhD in
athetics in um university of Madrid he's
actually a a professor as well name yeah
and yeah and he's actually a super super
cool guy and he was the one to recommend
me this book he he he he told me that
once we were having discussions because
we have this materialist group that we
have U Gatherings and we even do like
live Gatherings we did a couple in
Mexico last year and last time we got
together he I told him like what are you
reading currently what would you
recommend and he told me I'm just
starting this book on metamodernism by
by Jason Ananda and you should really
take a look on it and and let me know
what you think and I was like okay I'll
take it so then uh I started reading
into it and then another friend of mine
that is also another philosopher from
Costa Rica told me he was reading
another book on metamodernism but not
the same one because this is this is
also something we can which one do you
guys read the one metamodernism and the
future of theory from Jason Ananda yeah
we read the future of theory yeah looked
at Jason storm yeah Jason from storm and
then there's another one from two guys
that created a ponm of a avatar that is
the one doing the writing something like
that the hanzi one yeah H hzi fry hanzi
fry and yeah and they created like this
ponm to to to do the writing so that's
how I got into in touch with um with
meta modernism and for me like what I
found interesting is that between the
let's say what we normally get from uh
traditional philosophy and when I I I
say traditional philosopher I mean like
for example my brother is also doing his
Masters in um uh ethics of AI so he's
very much into classic philosophy in
very much into analytic philosophy as
well we get a lot of these like
transcendental categories and it's one
of the things that I got from this book
is that he he starts Shing on
transcendental categories a lot like
advising us of the danger of using these
transcendental categories to organize
our worldview and and a lot of uh
disciplines they they tend to hide the
meaning behind this transcendental
categories and they hide the fact that
most of them are based on either lies or
just pure [__] on the other side he
he kind of tried to to criticize
postmodernism by just being that you
know like staring into the the the like
the the cynicism and the and the nism in
a way saying okay so we cannot address
any type of Truth we cannot truly
construct any type of uh stable
knowledge so let's not even attempt to
to to produce any knowledge which I know
is like a a strowman version of what
postmodernism stands for yeah this is a
this is a Jordan Peterson argument yeah
which I found reflected very much in
this book oh yeah absolutely I
understand that perfectly so I think
these guys like he he he's making strans
of of Dera of delus and like most of the
postmoderns he he quotes he he seems not
to really understand them that well but
he takes this position of saying okay so
we can get some knowledge out of this
fact that we cannot build uh our society
on transcendental categories but we can
also just not stand back and take and
and like drop ourselves into theism and
say we cannot aspire to any type of
knowledge so let's do something that he
calls zetic knowledge I think is I think
is in chapter six or seven something
like that yeah I saw that is his
consideration about humble knowledge
which is a lot of like re rehashed
Oriental philosophy fism too I would say
yeah abduction fallibilism exactly and
then he proposes this notion of what we
should Aspire through is is to is to get
humble knowledge which is also very much
connected in a way to what my friends in
Spain are working on which is um generic
naturalism and it's a it's a
philosophical system that is uh rooted
on the notion of of the generation of
know process philosophy process oriented
philosophy a lot of heraclitus and and
going back to this notion that we have
to be much more aware of systems and
processes and how these systems and
processes give the possibility of of new
uh generation of knowledge and events
and pay much more attention to that than
actually to be you know like committed
and completely in in a in a Eternal
Marriage with these Master categories so
I think that that was the one thing that
got me interested into this book uh I
gave it a red and uh I don't know that's
pretty much it well you might be talking
to the right people because we've been
on a systems theory Nicholas Lumen kick
for the last couple episodes I know
remember I'm a hardcore user of the
plastic
pills before we actually try to look at
this text I want to say I'm I'm probably
going to react to this differently than
I usually react to to text and that's
particularly because when someone's
claiming to have invented the wheel and
you know it's in the subtitle this this
is the future of theory when someone's
claiming to have invented the wheel I
think you can hold that claim to a
higher standard than you would hold a
podcast to for example cuz I referenced
postmodernism I wouldn't say frequently
but often enough it's mostly ironically
uh but by his definition I am a
postmodernist and I don't be appreciate
being told that this fresh new theory is
going to alaben me so this might be the
most analytic the listeners have heard
me get and I'm going to use quotations
if we if we get that far but if if we
weren't recording on this I have to
admit if we weren't recording on this
book I I would have thrown the book away
after page two and then again after page
11 and then again after chapter
5 you you read all the way to chapter
five no I only read chapter five because
it's in the area that Eric and I kind of
specialize in okay perfect so yeah this
is hyos semiotics chapter htics yeah I
mean yeah I I I think the first thing to
get over with this book is just kind of
the the grandiose kind of very ambitious
promises like like here's like in some I
aim to move Beyond deconstruction by
radicalizing it or turning it inside out
this may sound paradoxical negating
negativity is actually the beginning of
a positive gesture that authorizes the
new accumulation of knowledge etc etc
like you got go like that's the flavor
of it it it's very it doesn't feel very
original yeah sounds almost almost like
Jordan Peterson the originality kind of
lies in this Grand synthetic I mean I
mean he's promising to get everything
like the a whole epistemological program
for the Humanities all of it human
Sciences
arts and even the Sciences just
everything he wants to overturn and
there's there's some really really big
claims that are a bit hard to swallow
and maybe would put people in a bit of a
defensive posture once you're as you
read through the
opening and this is because we're doing
an episode on metamodernism there's
actually metam modernisms already but I
think the main gesture is that we have
these historical stages and not
necessarily temporal historical but you
know like uh trends at least Fashions
and their ideas that postmodernism has
failed like whatever the [__] that means
I honestly have no idea what it means to
say that postmodern M has failed but
anyway postmodernism was a stage it has
failed and now we need to name the next
thing and they want it to be their thing
so it's
metamodernism yes it seems like the
naming game is is U is very important to
this guy like I'll tell you why Diego
it's because people need citations yeah
citations is how you create a career
yeah if if feel it feels very much like
a project that is like um you know like
like this this grandos notion of getting
over everything at the same time and
proposing the future of theory and you
know this sentence that you just read
Eric sounded like it could be something
Peterson could have said you know like
this gesture of overcoming is like
sounds a little bit too grandiose and
self self-entitled to be to be real and
also like this this notion of having to
name everything like to like this
necessity to idealistically overcome a a
determined period of time it seems like
oh my God too much yeah we we need a
copernic Revolution we need to revolve
the human Sciences on their axis it's
like it's very very I mean this guy
doesn't look a day over 40 and yet this
is like he's he's sort of asking us to
trust that he has the life experience
and the knowledge to pull this off which
is it's I mean it's it's ambitious and I
could give him credit for and and the
and the the range of reading like this
guy is undeniably
well read but it it also yeah it's a bit
tough to get through the introduction
without kind of rolling your eyes and
being like Oh another one of these
crisis of the humani kinds of books
right the same kinds of books we see
periodically for the past like 200 years
it's another
one I'd also read this as a sort of
postmodern historicism where it's super
over reflexive and you name the movement
when there is no movement which is to
like pay for all the branding when you
don't when you haven't sold any product
yet because everything is just branding
in images anyway so I'd say that's
postmodern in that it's simulating
Revolution this naming branding
declaring yourself a rupture
revolutionary of all the disciplines at
the same
time I mean like well Eric you called it
ambitious I don't know I find
it not even arrogant as much as it's
like quick sodic this is the definition
of tilting at windmills maybe for me it
was refreshing since I'm from the
outside of the Academia like like since
you guys are like much closer to this is
probably that's why you got this this
impression so I'm really interested can
can we go into some of the ideas that he
presented like specifically Hollow
semiotics what what's your take on
it I'd rather can we just start with
postmodernism please I I I need to get
this out of the way cuz it's like an an
itch that if I don't scratch I'll just
you'll exp self-d
destruct this seems to me like a
pathology that is we look at a
historically impossibly complex
narrative it's the the history of the
West is one version of that this is just
another version of it to my mind that we
have these divided chapters one ends
then we start a new chapter of course
this isn't how it works but the the the
idea that we need a new thing because
I'm not happy with the thing and then I
look around and I see postmodernism
everywhere and I blame that thing for
all the problems that I see in the
University which is like what material
speaking it's like the the
differentiation of the humanities that
has nothing to do with these material
conditions that involve a publicly
funded model of an increasingly
irrelevant institution the university in
this case which is a degree Mill uh your
demand to overproduce and write articles
these unreadable books so that people
can compete for fewer and fewer
positions and the pro this guy thinks
like at one point he implies that
metamodernism will solve global warming
right so this is what we're dealing with
the problem is not that we need a new
chapter in The History of Thought So if
someone's GNA say this is the new stage
the new historical stage is going to be
metamodernism this if he if he had read
bodard unfortunately I control AF and
there's only two references he says
bodard is accused of being a
postmodernist and says nothing else
about it but this is the simulation of a
historical shift it's the sense that we
need to do the new thing because shifts
in ideas throughout history are what
cause history and there are good ideas
and there are bad ideas and
postmodernism was a bad
idea again I have no idea what the [__]
that means but it failed somehow it's
nothing material and the charitable
interpretation of it is like this is
this is cute this is cute that he wants
to try it I'm I'm kind of embarrassed
the University of Chicago press
published this because it is the other
side of the coin of Jordan Peterson with
more references admitted
like well read very well cited very I
mean they're not always the most
relevant citations but I mean he's
backed loads and loads into his endnotes
bibliography oh yeah like 12% of the
book is crazy yeah there like 60 pages
but I want to know what postmodernism is
there's not a single direct reference to
a postmodernist because he
names uh let me let me name them here a
second
uh okay I can do it from memory it is
Delo yeah bodard Dara Fuko
igare and Ry and he says that
postmodernism is not these people it's
just the Americans that have read these
people now I don't know who the people
that have read these people are you mean
like Judith Butler do you mean Paul
deand do you mean like there there are
postmodernists that have taken over the
university in his View and every student
who comes into the university has to
adhere to postmodernism and then he goes
back on himself and says yeah but
postmodernism is not actually a thing
sometimes he calls it a movement
sometimes he calls it a paradigm and
there's no actual Target here which
drove me insane because if I could check
your 12% of your book that is footnotes
then I could find the postmodernist that
you're talking about but he's talking
about people who are talking about
postmodernism which doesn't hostile
critics he tends to site the people who
are critical of postmodernism which is a
bit like unfair if you're going to make
an argument like this you should you
know cite the critics cite the people
who are in favor of it cite the actual
postmodernists you're accusing of being
postmodernists many of whom deny that
they're postmodernists and then and then
try to try to come to a kind of reasoned
conclusion about it don't just present
The critic's View and then sort of you
know say well I know postmodernists
don't really say these things or at
least if you take them individually but
like I'm just going to deal with this
caricature of the whole thing anyway
because it's more convenient and that
that's the sort of danger of labeling
right like instead of considering the
the specificity of the time and place
and what the people are actually saying
you can kind of just like step up a
level and just kind of gather them all
into a label and then generalize and and
that that creates a bit of
a it's it's creates a bit of a problem
right because you want you know you want
these claims to be cited and and then
you know show that your critiques are
either brand new or cite people before
you whove like it's just doing the work
you know and but he's clearly got a much
more expansive purpose in mind and he's
kind of doing his own
thing and and it's like okay well if I
actually to learn about these people and
ideas he's bringing up I'd have to go
somewhere else because because he's
doing his own thing here he's not really
sort of he's he's being very syncretic
syn syncretism syncretic philosophy he
putting a lot of stuff together and then
that's the question is what's the
criteria of this selection well anytime
I'll Stand in for the postmodernist here
because he named my three main guys
which is uh Dera bodard Delo yeah yeah
see see some Lan and Fuko in there too
except he never he never addresses uh
either bodard or doas even I think he
says assemblage maybe one time but uh
deconstruction he wants to
deconstruct so I'm a little bit confused
by it but no if if I I'll defend uh
deconstruction if it if it comes to that
like this is I think I don't think he
even understands the construction
property to be honest with you like most
of the time he was talking about de
construction and the little I understand
about de construction he was not fully
grasping the notion of what it means
like he he even makes this reference
that you know like these Master
categories from from Modern thought they
have these archimedian points that give
them
um as a point of sustenance and a point
of of rooting in order to be these
Master categories but but then he
criticizes deconstruction like saying
like man I don't think he truly gets it
because that's exactly what de
construction was getting through the
fact that these Master categories have a
reality or a truth outside of the text
to sustain them you know like they they
depend on this archimedian point that is
outside but most of the time he speaks
about either derida Deus and even like I
don't know fuk that much but like you
said bodri he doesn't he sites but he
doesn't get into detail it seems like he
built this trauma of postmodernism but
doesn't necessarily address anything in
particular he just paints it as this
what what people think postmodern
postmodernism is and he attacks that you
know he doesn't attack any of the of the
specific uh authors and specific line of
lines of thoughts or or the tools that
that he actually uses in the text which
is kind of confusing yeah yeah and he
was talking about Vicken Stein and the
linguistic term and Vicken Stein and I'm
like okay well Vicken Stein was pretty
big and if you read you know if you read
the leotard book yeah leotard is looking
at Vicken Stein but but it it doesn't
seem to come into play if you look at
you know dered Do's work is more
oriented towards sueran Linguistics and
structuralism and ly Strauss and you
know he tells the one story but then you
kind of want the rest of it I mean I
guess if if you're kind of if you kind
of know there are other stories about
this stuff out there you kind of want to
say well like why is this the
representative story that he kind of
went with and and he makes these you
know he does qualify his claims like
here here's a flavor of it post
modernists were the can the canonical
postmodernists were not exaggerated
voluntarists of the sort criticized by
many contemporary realists they argued
for a gamut of different positions and
then and then here we go to the
generalizing many of them were basically
skeptical neocon yeah but yeah and then
the postmodernist thinkers who came
closest to anti-realism typically did so
through the methodological suspension of
linguistic
reference
I'm like is that is that is that the
case is that
true talk detail in chapter five okay so
I got to go to chapter
five but like the thing is if you're
gonna just name okay the Canon thinkers
of postmodernism are bodz Dar Fuko irar
and uh Ry yeah those people hated each
other at different
times hard to think of them as a team
Del and Fuko made up but they all
bodard um like where do you get a cannon
from this this is like an insane even
suggestion to make but then he goes oh
no no no I'm not talking about them
specifically I'm talking about people
who read them and then doesn't site the
people who read them so again I don't
know what yeah who's he's talking about
yeah we have to put that aside because
otherwise we're just going to be talking
about that forever but there is no
postmodernism he also says oh there is
not actually a postmodernism but then
continues to talk about it
as if there
is but uh okay we got a few ways to go
here I'm so tired I'm so tired of this
like we need an anti-foundationalist
foundation and we need to deconstruct
deconstruction and even more radical
there's a couple things right so new
philosophical movements those are hard
to start because they're always met with
a lot of skepticism like I I remember
being introduced to speculative realism
and I'm reading
maasu and then I'm sort of interested in
lure and then I'm like okay Graham
Harmon's a reader of Lor and I read
about object-oriented ontology and like
to be completely Fair those those they
were great philosophies and they had
interesting things to say correlationism
for example from the and he cites this
he talks about this in the book I'm not
saying he's ignoring this stuff I'm just
saying that this is the fir it is common
to try to you know break out of these
sort of old patterns and traditions and
and labels and try to make something new
and you're met with all this skepticism
I mean it's very common and and I I do
sympathize with someone who's trying
to I guess expand the uh
institutionalized academic Horizons in
in this way and yeah the many of the
things he says about current Academia I
wouldn't defend Academia at all against
his claims right yeah like but in terms
of like this is this is like a proposal
for this is how we should read it maybe
that this is a proposal for something
new that could potentially replace this
and I'm just like well okay yeah I'll
I'll take you at your word and and read
what you have to say on that basis
something that I find really naive in
the book like he has this metaphor about
metamor modernism I don't know if if I
recall it correctly is either lightning
or thunder I don't know he sites one of
the two lightning is it yeah so he has
like I I found it kind of naive to say
that the the notion of metamodernism is
to the lightning that strikes down and
deconstructs whatever Master category is
trying to criticize but instead of just
deconstructing it uses electricity to
produce something new okay so but but
how do you know you're not reproducing
the same biases that we the ones that
created those Master categories to begin
with you know like that that that's that
that's what I found really naive about
the sense that okay he that he doesn't
really understand what deconstruction
means yeah yeah and I wouldn't claim to
be an expert in deconstruction by any
means I would claim that and I will the
problem if someone comes up to me and
says there are no such thing as stars
I'd be like okay you're probably wrong
but I'm not a scientist I don't have the
knowledge to to disprove what you're
saying so okay fine there are no stars
they're just're whatever yeah but but
this but this actic like
accep how do you say it in English ex
like esceptico uh oh skeptic skeptic
yeah sorry so this skeptic point of view
is kind of like uh is his undertone in
in most of his statements like but but
he's skeptic towards postmodernism which
is which is weird for me like he's he's
pretending to criticize modernism by
being skeptic of postmodernism without
defining what postmodernism is oh it's
like you know using deconstruction to
deconstruct deconstruction and then out
of this we'll get through you know it's
not about disavowing postmodernism I'm
like okay that's a good point it's about
going through it right Break On Through
To The Other Side uh using its own tools
and strategies and I'm like okay well
then you got to think well what's the
substance of that is it is that
scholarship or is that
is that like something else is that
movement building is that you know we
have to solve climate change we have to
is that like more just an aggregation of
moral Communications rather than you
know actual
scholarship yeah no this is this is
definitely for dupes it's trying to
create a a movement can I just I'm going
to di tribe here for a bit just to
explain deconstruction what it is and
what it isn't cuz diida is the one who
fits into his his little categories
which are postmodernism deconstruction
post structuralism and French Theory so
der is in every one of those categories
to some degree or another uh but he also
says that postmodernism is like
anti-realist is Dara an
anti-realist unqualified no first of all
but let's look at what Dara does as
compared to what this guy does this guy
wants to start with these broad
conceptions of what he thinks these
terms mean what the university is what
the University is doing wrong does Dera
do that at all no no he reads into text
very
specifically Dara does humble knowledge
which is apparently something that this
guy wants so what does he do he takes a
book this is I'll just summarize the
1968 books because there's three of them
he takes a book by uh so sir or rouso or
hurl and reads it and reads it carefully
Hegel y glass when he reads it then what
happens well he finds that there's an
oppositional binary at key points in the
text or what's like a binary opposition
between a term that they're valuing a
term that is supplementing the value of
that term so presence and absence is the
main one for example or speech and text
or in uh phenomenology expression and
indication and then what happens well
each of these authors suer rouso HL
Hegel wrote an entire book on one side
of the binary assuming that it was
primary without proving that it's
primary so the medium itself the book
for
example contradicts the Primacy of
speech over text because there's no
speech in a text so what happens then
the text deconstructs itself dereda is
not the deconstructor in this sense he
is showing that there is an internal
contradiction in these certain seminal
works that everyone was reading at a
time is that a master category [__] no
it's not he's just reading one book and
then did Dara go on to say oh hey now
the world isn't real no like he pointed
out he pointed out one thing in each of
the books that he was reading carefully
systematically trying to prove that
there was something in there that was
based on an unproven assumption so does
the book deconstruct itself did he draw
the conclusion that there is no outside
text or does the text itself fail to
prove that there is an outside text
given the way that it's written and I
think you know my answer to all these
questions
this is a process that took dared 300
pages in each book to do reading One
Singular text to say that like so sir
deconstructs himself by assuming that
speech is primary and text is secondary
where there is no speech
now that's pretty simple to me I think
that's a a careful reading there's not
antology arguments there's no broad
climate of skepticism it's just that
text if you read them carefully
sometimes contradict themselves
internally and then to say this is what
deconstruction is in in my short version
of it and then to say we need to
deconstruct deconstruction oh but not
darod does deconstruction we just want
to deconstruct other people's
deconstruction this is exactly the
opposite of what I'd call Humble reading
or careful reading or faithfulness or
charity cuz if there's anyone who did
all those things it is there
who's like implicitly a Target here
because we have to deconstruct
deconstruction calming myself down Brea
in a little
bit calm down pill take a pill take a
pill but everyone says this everyone
says this about Dara all the time
there's no world blah blah blah it's not
true it's just it's just madeup [__] and
he wasn't setting out to start a
movement called
poststructuralism he wasn't setting out
to do any of this stuff stuff he was
just reading carefully for his like PhD
project that's it and then all this
other ascription of reality denial
skepticism deconstructing Master
categories he never would have said any
of that [__] yeah yeah he was just like
very careful reading the books that he
read and dedicating it like to showing
the contradictions within the text
itself I agree like I I agree is a much
better example of humble knowledge than
to say we're going to revolutionize the
future of theory and humble knowledge
yeah yeah and and I like I I like the
idea of of humanity is like
non-instrumental liable knowledge but
but then you're totally
instrumentalizing deconstruction to this
end when deconstruction is a theory of
text it's not it's a broader
philosophical theory of text it's not
it's not meant to you know say anything
final about some
individual book but I mean that's okay
that's Dara's kind of way of things like
take it or leave it I'm not I'm not yeah
and it's also very naive to the logic of
capital and the production of
knowledge I mean even even less than a
theory of text it's just a it's just a
method he's just presenting a method not
even presenting a method for other
people to do he was just doing it so
when you say we want to move past
postmodernism you want to move past
Dara's close reading of text because it
failed what the [__] do you mean it
failed did he or did he not show that
there were contradictions if he didn't
then show that he didn't you don't just
say oh you failed so we're gonna do
something else now yeah yeah for me for
me again it falls into this into this
like um again like again ideas don't
change the world you know like any
anyone can pretend to say like this is
the one the one movement this is the one
tool this is the one Theory this is the
one New Concept that is going to push us
forward and then again like we fall back
into materialism it's like no it's it's
not like that you can say as many fancy
words as you want you can change master
categories as much as you want you can
rename your book in fancy ways but it's
but it's not going to move us forward
because whatever is keeping us the way
we are is the thing that has to change
in order for us to move forward like we
cannot will ourselves by our bootstraps
by our ideological bootstraps out out of
a a moment in
history yeah I mean here this is of my
favorite I got to say moving into
chapter two now as if we're doing it
chapter by chapter this is chapter 2's
got to be my favorite here it's it's
pretty amazing to be honest I mean he's
he he brings up he he brings up research
in in a whole whack of different
disciplines and dis he's talking about
disciplinary object so religion studying
religion culture studies studying
culture literature whatever all right
what's the object he says and and he
kind of brings up all these different
texts that critique these things and say
well if you're in a discipline say
psychology then you have to Define what
the mind is and if you can't Define what
the mind is then you have no discipline
and you're illegitimate but he says here
okay these these various critiques
deployed an overlapping set of
intellectual moves and it's possible to
abstract from them a set of strategies
for destroying disciplinary
objects brackets for the source from
which the following is generalized see
the mother of all endnotes 46 and then
indeed I scrolled down and it was a
three-page [__] end note organized
into subcategories with culture religion
science the word culture had a
subcategory of postcolonialism like he
just just and there must be like 200
texts there he basically builds a
syllabus for four courses in one endnote
and then he continues you know to be
clear the epistemological and rhetorical
strategies underpinning what he calls
here autoc
critique though
routinized are no less valid for that
don't mistake my tone I'm deadly serious
despite the intentional provocation of
what follows I do not think these
strategies are mere sophistry rather
they rest on real philosophical issues
which tell us something fundamental
about the way we have been
misunderstanding categories in their
relationship to the world and here comes
a fun sentence in what follows I will
demonstrate how this works offering what
is basically an Anarchist Cookbook or
deconstructive dojo for subversive
academics okay and then it does it
literally is that step one collect
competing
definitions couple paragraphs step two
expose internal contradictions step
three disaggregate the concept step four
collapse the implicit binary I'm I'm
skipping to each step but each one is
followed by a paragraph of examples and
things and he goes on like this in this
is the imminent critique and then the
relativizing critique another step one
historicize step two uh optional but but
identify the victims genealogical
critique who's the victim you know art
constitutes Itself by excluding The
Artisan for
example and then relativize step three
relativize the cultural context again
optional uh you relativize the cultural
context the Japanese had no indigenous
term for religion for example right so
he's he's a Japanese he's he's a scholar
of Eastern religions that's what he got
his degree in uh so I mean okay that's
fine Chinese the Chinese have no native
term for word yeah that makes sense it's
relativized the cultural context and
then there's the ethical critique and it
go kind of goes on like that for a
little while so it's that there's his
sort of uh deconstructive Dojo Anarchist
Cookbook so you can just take a bunch of
definitions show how they're all
different so you know what's the
definition of society okay I can find
all these definitions of society and
they don't agree they all exclude things
that others include
and it's a very much I I don't even know
what to make of that but it's pretty
[__] fun to read I gotta say why why
did you bring this up then Eric yeah
because this is his deconstruction that
you were just talking about this is his
version of deconstruction which involves
deconstruction is collecting definitions
and showing that they don't all add up
to one total okay yeah like get all the
definitions together and show how they
kind of exclude and contradict one
another and I mean yeah okay that's like
so sir was writing to to try and figure
out what is the object of linguistics
it's language but what is language is it
speech is it vocal cords is it what is
it is it conversation no he abstracts
from all that Lumen same thing what is
the social the problem of the unity of
the social has haunted sociology since
it's beginning what do we do let's
replace it with a distinction system
environment like this is a constant
problem through all the disciplines and
he points this out and maybe maybe
somebody should be paying attention to
this [__] problem if you're paying so
much goddamn money to go to these places
and learn these things but again to be
to present it in this way is very kind
of
justu gen what's the word swys it just
came he just picked it out of his mind
and here it is yeah I'm I'm going to
come from religious studies which is
also the lowest of all the Humanity's
disciplines you know we got philosophy
on top then like then history then
literature
then sociology and then a then a few
rungs down then you have religious
studies but he's going to solve all the
problems of the disciplines in three
paragraphs from from
religion yeah yeah every time every time
I hear like he starts with this framing
what did he said Anarchist Dojo he said
something like that no he said Anarchist
Anarchist cbook which is where which is
how you learn how to make pipe bombs so
you can blow up your high school yeah
yeah it's Napal orange juice and like
yeah it's like like lately more and more
I'm becoming like allergic to the to the
term
Anarchist like every time somebody
somebody starts a position like
especially a a philosophical position
from anarchism I'm already like doubting
like I'm pre- doubting everything well
this is a bit of something I thought too
this is a bit of a maybe a a tinge or
maybe maybe I'm getting it from other
metam modernists but it does have a
tinge of leftwing libertarianism to it
very like kind of
individualistic kind of [__] the system
he's he's trying to build a movement a
build a movement where all people can
like accomplish human flourishing in all
the disciplines
together any moment which is why he's
being
interdisciplinary while at the same time
acting is a gra a great case example of
why you shouldn't be interdisciplinary
because you talk [__] about other
disciplines that you have no clue about
or he says at the end of the book
postmodernism might look at this book
and say that's just modernism but I'm a
postmodernist for intents and purposes
in this discussion and I look at this
and I go oh this is more post this is a
branding exercise like first and
foremost it's a pi Piper hey everybody
buy into my program site me and follow
me in my weird
idiosyncratic solution to the internal
problems of every discipline and
defining your object is difficult it's
difficult for
probably all the reasons that he said
and others that he's not even aware of
what happens when metamodernism gets a
bunch of different definitions which it
already has already has exactly you
think you think when you're looking at
somebody who's say like a sociologist
they would choose which meaning they're
referring to like just say the social
but then they're going to Define it and
and if they can't Define it then that's
a problem but that's a problem that
sustains the discipline itself it's not
a it's not a problem for the existence
of the dis
displine it's like it's like why why Lor
re
redefines the social as associations
between actors and a network and somehow
it's postmodernism's fault that
disciplines don't interact more or you
know maybe they're competing with
funding with professors in their own
department so they're trying to push
their own and Aristotle's fault for
setting the agenda for the Sciences in
such a shitty confusing way that that
21st century people can't understand
like shame on
them but I mean just be to again to be
[__] charitable like yeah I mean I
agree with the spirit of what he's
saying I'm just not always sure about
you know the like do I buy into this if
not is some of it valuable and and I'd
say yeah but it's maybe maybe that's
part of the problem that he's trying to
um refer to too much being too vague and
Broad about it yeah it's a bit it's a
bit superficial yeah feels it feels
shallow most time yeah surface reading
but not a lot of depth maybe you'd ask
for some more depth in certain places
but I mean again to back up and say yeah
the great system Builders of of
philosophy right he mentions Hegel as
the last system builder which he's not
correct you know Charles Sanders purse
after Charles Sanders purse talot
Parsons after talot Parson Lumen there's
lots of system builders in fact Lumen
system which we've been doing for the
past couple weeks yeah is absolutely
insane you should read that and try to
compare your system building to you know
read P's article the architecture of
theories he's very explicit about how
he's going to replace Aristotle's system
and what needs to be done and the same
with Lumen he's very explicit about how
he's basing his system building on a few
very firm and deeply planted Concepts
drawn from General systems theory but
this is more like um an itemized list of
all the ideas that he wants to be
associated with it which is not a system
it's that's I'd call that a network the
network of ideas that are just kind of
connected to each other but maybe they
don't really support each other in a
systematic kind of way maybe they
contradict themselves and comparably
lum's system took him
35 years and like six books to write he
didn't try to do it in one chapter yeah
he started it when he was 30 years old
he finished it when he was 1995 I think
he published his theory of society so
yeah since 1965 to
1995 and he was an old [__] man by
that point died right after so he'd been
but he's a lumen is also a very bad
example to compare yourself to cuz he's
a bit of a he's a bit of a bright one
he's a bright bulb and it's very
frustrating but like look at this
opening to his article why does society
describe itself as postmodern see if
like try to see if metamodernism would
escape this critique Lumen says the
discussion about modern or postmodern
Society operates on the semantic level
in it we find many references to itself
many descriptions of descriptions but
hardly any attempt to take reality into
account on the operational and
structural level of social
Communications were we to care for
realities we would not see any sharp
break between modern and a post-modern
society for centuries we've had a
monetary economy and still have it
perhaps there are signs that indicate a
new centrality of financial markets or
Banks or portfolio strategies that
marginalize money spent for investment
and consumption but it is and remains an
economic system differenti ated by
transactions that use money we've also
had a state oriented polit political
system for centuries and we still have
it positivistic legal system he goes
through everything and just says yeah
yeah our our our whole life depends on
Technologies today more so than ever and
again we see more problems but no clear
break with the past no transition from a
modern to a postmodern Society now if
you're of this
persuasion uh you would just consider
metamodernism to be an extension of
postmodernism which is an extension of
modernism and not anything different in
kind just in degree basically which is
also a very local form of observation of
General observation which is academic
specifically yeah so to go on to say
we're going to have like multispecies
flourishing if we get the right
ideas I don't even know that's just it's
nonsense I don't know what else to call
it it's dog dog water I do like Storm's
idea that um I mean I think the same
kind of goes for the way that he sort of
he acknowledges the complexity of
postmodern thought but then he kind of
deals with a more generalized version to
put it nicely uh he also deals very well
I think what he says applies exactly to
a lot of what is going on in Humanities
like what a lot of non not dairy does
are writing or what a lot of What Not
Del l or I don't know not Donna herway
or whatever they're writing a lot of
stuff to try and reveal that the
categories are blurred like the whole
sort of end of a humani project is to
show that we're in this hybrid Lial
border state and the and the categories
and distinctions that we are kind of
used to using are no longer valid and I
think he makes a great point that that
should not be the end goal of Humanity's
scholarship that we need to do something
more positive than that something that's
going to be beneficial to I don't know I
don't want to sort of jump on the say
yeah beneficial to humanity you know a
philosophy of human flourishing like
Martha nus bomb style but I mean I think
he he
does he says a lot of things and so some
of them are bound to hit the mark and I
think he does hit the mark in some of
those places where he's
criticizing the kind of contemporary
Academy the problem is there's like
there's causal there's causal reasons
for why the university is the way that
it is and none of them are because the
humanities were influenced by Dara Fuko
bodard
Etc and it's not like this is new
there's like there's an endless slew of
books and New Yorker articles that says
this kind of thing the it's not the
first call for a renewal of the humanity
to their once great position in society
like H wrote a book on this like a 100
years ago for God's sake so yeah the
diagnosis might be true but the problems
ultimately are for sure not disciplinary
the problem is not that there's too many
dead white men on the syllabus and the
problem is also not that the radical
woke left are trying to take the dead
white men off the syllabus as the the
conservatives will say the problem is
with the structure of the University
especially in uh neoliberal context the
financial incentives of departments or
Publishers or professors and the
incentives of students who are going to
University like like why are you trying
to take me to or force me to take a a
literature course I'm just trying to go
to dental school and not one of these
problems or conditions is internal to
the university either they're largely
economic because there are better
incentives else elere and largely
technological like why would I waste all
this time paying tuition to read books
when I have uh Wikipedia and YouTube If
I want to know something so the
university and the humanities
specifically are quite honestly simply
not very compelling when you consider
the goals of most people now I would
like this to change just like storm
would like it to
change like of course this is is what I
care about too but postmodernist
professors didn't cause anything that
he's describing and a new research plan
that's a bunch of neologisms cobbled
together arbitrarily from one from his
own brain that's is this is just
irrelevant I wanted to bring up
one
point well we Diego wanted us to take a
look at chapter
five that's where my point comes from
because he talks about purse and and and
I've had some dealings with purse you
know we've talked about this on the
podcast before he he he gets soer wrong
but he gets the structuralist
interpretation of soer
right so again this is like remember
when we did that episode on the chair
that that Netflix show and they brought
David doovy sort of out of academic
retirement to uh
to sort of give a he wrote his
dissertation on Becket I think in the
show and uh I mean he was playing
himself in the show confusingly David
dney as David dney is that the guy from
xfiles yeah that's xfiles Cali
fornication whatever guy and uh he uh
yeah he so he read his dissertation and
he got all this critique it's like you
wrote this in the' 60s man so much has
happened since where's your post
Colonial where's your gender critique
where's all this like new stuff that's
come out and and he's like oh I just got
invited here I didn't I didn't want to
get deal with all that and this is kind
of the I mean that's a bad analogy but
there's just some of the areas that he
looks at here are not super up todate so
I mean that soer story yes it is very
very common I was taught that story and
I know it is wrong because I've been
into semiotics for a while and and
that's so sir didn't necessarily even
write the course that was written by two
editors who using the student notes very
selectively and adding a lot of their
own stuff so that whole line about
language must be studied in and for
itself was an editorial Edition it's not
something but that became a very popular
Mantra among structuralists doesn't
sorted and and complicated history there
but I mean he doesn't even gesture to
that and then
I just want to point out one thing Pur
develop here's a quote Pur developed his
triotic model of semiotics as a
rejection of the then prevalent
communication
model Can you spot anything possibly
wrong with that you're gonna have to
read it again I was reading something
else Pur developed his triotic model Pur
developed his triotic model of semiotics
as a rejection of the then prevalent
communication
model communication is in scare quotes
in a communication model this will help
language is best understood in terms of
a sender who emits a signal and the
purpose of communicating a message to a
receiver with the purpose with the
purpose oh yeah because he's using that
that model is from the 40s and Pur wrote
like 50 or 60 years before that yeah
then prevalent communication model is
the Shannon Weaver model Shannon
published in the 1940s Pur was dead by
then for 30 years
yeah Pur is not rejecting the then
prevalent communication model because
purse was not alive then it was not
current Shannon published the
mathematical theory of communication in
1948 the same year that Norbert vaner
published cybernetics communication
control the animal the machine 1948 Pur
died in
1913 I think it was so Pur was not
rejecting the then prevalent
communication model because it was not
then prevalent it did not exist and just
I mean it again the S Sur thing the
purse thing like these seem like little
kind of nitpicky points and they really
are but I
mean how much how we're nitpicking on
the one thing that we know about so how
much of the rest should be nitpicked
over that that's a red flag yeah like
how how can I trust the other areas that
I'm not a specialist in if I see glaring
kind of you know fast and looseness here
and it's it's difficult it's it's tough
for me to be I want to be nice but you
know the percan sign is triotic because
it consists in a relationship between a
signifier its signified meaning or
reference and its interpret on why use
the curan vocabulary when Pur developed
his own
vocabulary represent object interpretan
also he turns the interpretan into
whatever he calls a sentient or like
conscious interpreter right yeah he
makes a very basic error of of yeah
conflating The
Interpreter with this technical term
that P came up with interpretant if he
meant interpreter why would he come up
with a [__] ugly ass word like
interpretant he would because the
interpretan is the effect of the sign on
whatever interpretive agency sometimes
he calls it a quasi mind that the sign
determines object determines an effect
on the sign sign determines an effect on
the interpretive agency I would call it
and that whatever that interpretation is
is is you know I emit a yell I go H and
someone looks at me that that look that
turning of attention towards the sound
of my voice that's the interpretant and
it doesn't involve the whole being of
the person it's not The Interpreter or
their interpretation it is just a effect
of a sign like feeding a feeding a
feeding a a card into a uh into one of
those old school coding systems right
and then the code comes out the machine
interprets the signs and then hopefully
a human eventually interprets what the
machine has interpreted to make it a
full sign is this the chapter where he
talks about social kinds and and methods
of stabilization between signify
signified I think that might be the
prior one but he brings it up again here
social kinds yeah yeah it's not exactly
here but he does go into biosemiotics
and some stuff so it's like I'm I'm very
happy that that he included this Stu
that was probably my that was probably
my favorite part of the book is I think
it's chapter four then then the one he
goes into social kinds and this is
chapter five I was reading from yeah
chapter four is the one he goes into the
stability process of like the material
stability process of the relationship
between signifier and signifier which I
found quite interesting like again and
again I see like the the the stuff that
I don't relate to with this book is his
idealism like his um you know like this
uh autonomy of the subject like the the
autonomy of Concepts the autonomy of
Notions the the you know how ideas
trigger change like when he goes into
that it gets really really weak yeah and
he like hand waves away likeon at some
point like like you're just you're going
to handwave that and then like
reintroduce the subject as a conscious
agent in your semiotic structure cuz he
makes the same error that he did with
purse with so sir which is like so sir
wanted to deny the world or actually
I'll just quote it because it's it's uh
attempting to be nuanced without any
Nuance I should say so quote
postmodernism is consistently identified
as part of a broader linguistic term now
I highlighted consistently identified
who the [__] are you talking about
moving on yeah show show me the
consistency the next sentence according
to the most common account of this turn
again what the [__] are you talking
about who whose account yeah what term
common knowledge it is as though
philosophy having translated all of its
problems into problems of language
became nothing more than a language game
or perhaps postmodernism or
poststructuralism represents the grand
finale of an increasing overemphasis on
the authority of language that finally
aband even the notion of linguistic
structures and rejected anything outside
of the free play of unattached
linguistic
signs so no one did that okay didn't
happen yeah who is he referring to I I
mean
it's I don't know like I'm baffled this
is like something that some people
sometimes say Dara did but he didn't
so but not really yeah yeah many
scholars tend to take as given to two
things about language that they inherit
from Swiss linguist Ferdinand so sir and
then he goes on to say language is
separate from the world language is not
separate from the world so sir never
said that he said at the beginning I'm
going to bracket my system I'm not going
to talk about how signs are produced
because I don't know how that happened
we still don't know how that happened as
far as I know but he bracketed for a
reason so that he can deal with language
not pole but language L long as system
break it into its two axes and deal with
it on its own because to deal with
everything at the same time would be
[__] arrogant but this guy is like no
I'm going to reintroduce the world into
my language system by saying that
animals use signs too therefore CER is
wrong yeah so roughly 50% of this book
I'd say is written in passive voice or
attributed to some vague group of like
he said many scholars many SCH Scholars
have identified it as this and then
saying philosophy finished and just
became a language game but why can you
not attest a single person who said that
Vicken Stein said something kind of like
that he said um most of the
philosophical problems we have can be
reduced to language and you can solve it
to language he's not a postmodernist so
who are the many scholars yeah are they
are they with us in the room right now
this is this is exactly you know like
it's exactly like the Jordan Peterson
gek debate when he just fin him off by
saying NE
marxists where are the postmodernists
dude this is like Jordan Peterson
because apparently they're everywhere
they're everywhere it's apparently
they're dominating the the publishing
academ like your you're publish he says
every student who goes to the school or
goes to University in the 80s to the
2000s has to adopt this code or whatever
where are they and why haven't you named
one you're naming like Vicken Stein
which is at
it's Arcane basically there's a bunch of
Vicken Stein Scholars sure there's a
bunch of bodard and Deliz scholar sure
but I there's not like every class you
have to run through these thinkers and
adopt what they say so because he hasn't
given any examples to the contrary I
honestly have no idea what he's talking
about having
spent 13 years straight in the exact
types of departments that he supposedly
are overrun by these people like I'm the
only if I even am a postmodernist which
I think is an absurd or a nonsensical
thing to say but in so far as I am I'm
the only one I know Eric isn't Victor
isn't where where are all these
people where are the
marxists yeah and I guess I'm probably
much closer to a Marxist than to a
postmodernist to be honest I mean this
this kind of book makes me just not
really even want to deal with labels
anymore I mean when I was in when I was
in literary studies I I learned about
modernism and that's not the same thing
as modern or modernity modernism refers
to you know Ezra pound and TS Elliott
and you know Hemingway and Fitzgerald
and gerud Stein like it's a literary
movement postmodernism like this kind of
recapitulates it right postmodernism was
uh I guess an architectural movement
movement kind of in art and architecture
and then Lear and it should have stayed
there because that makes sense because
there's a modernist style of art and
then the thing that comes next yeah
benefit of goddamn hindsight now yeah
maybe it should have been maybe leotard
should have chosen something different
art leotard said this was my worst
publication can't believe I can't
believe it got this much attention and
then he's just cited as like declaring
post bism to be a thing yeah he Nam the
thing notice this was the same thing
because in in two was it around 20092
those notes on post metamodernism came
out by the Dutch guys uh and they were
talking about again art and architecture
and and and things like that and then it
kind of got taken up into this sort of
philosophical kind of social political
movement or and it sort of recapitulates
the whole history of postmodernism just
very quickly and in a kind of digital
context where you have you know in say
we're I guess we're completely
globalized now I don't probably pretty
globalized in leotards time as well but
I mean we're not as Global we're talking
to each other right now I in the 1950s
I'd literally just be yelling at my
window in my living room but I'm talking
to you people so I mean there's new
context it's postmodernism in a new
digital context to me it's brand
building maybe these maybe these guys
are going to pull a a SoCal on on us on
an Alan SoCal us and then come out as
saying that this was published
intentionally as vaguely as possible
because they want to just to to to show
something out of the dynamic of Academia
projects well I think this appeals to
like a
certain a certain group of people I
let's let's refer to them because we'
referred to them before these are
20-year-old
males 20-year-old males who take a
gender studies course and go I don't
like this what is it then they hear the
term postmodernism and they go oh this
is postmodernism yeah I don't want that
I want to believe I want I I lost my
Evangelical Faith as a child so now I
need to have someone else to follow and
something else to believe in so this
person has all the answers let's sign up
well I think I think one thing here is
that okay if you're gonna give me like
12 rules for life by Peterson or this
book I'd say read this book in a second
I'd never I wouldn't even have to think
about it but what that does seem to say
is is there's some kind
of well you mentioned pill's pathology
and I think there is a
pathology that this book kind of appeals
to and it's it's you know that's we're
just talking about it's like religion
it's
spiritualism I I even this even kind of
struck me as almost like uh like uh New
England Trans American
transcendentalism or you know
spiritualism I say like if Arthur Conan
Doyle were alive he would be a [__]
modernists and he'd be saying like look
I found some fairies or something or or
if I don't know maybe maybe if you could
get a few people from the Golden Dawn
you know get some get some Yates or
aliser mck I I just think it's it's in
that Avenue like it appeals to people
who are looking for
more than postmodernism more meaning
yeah more meaning than postmodernism
kind of wants to offer you and and uh
and maybe something a little more than
just just like mechanistic science and
and sorry Diego materialism because it's
very D and serious it's it's not
spiritual it's not it doesn't have this
mean so I think there is a similarity
and then if you're just if your politics
is left maybe you'll go to you'll go
read some Ken Wilbur and if your
politics is on the right then you'll go
read one of those so-called Square
people who have swung very far to the
right at this point and something read
about how postmodernism is ruining
everything versus how postmodernism like
this book kind of says can be a sort of
tool to uh I don't know get through it
yeah you should watch P's video about
post postmodern is actually good and I I
agree I I share a lot of opinions from
that video as well I think I've I think
I've seen that
Prett pretty it's not bad this book says
this is like not even a deconstructive
critique by any means it just AAL quote
it baldly says like postmodernism is
good and then or it can be good for some
things and then only shits on it because
it destroyed whatever he thinks the
university should be which is fostering
some community of human flourishing
where we all uh hold hands but again
this is like a myopic understanding of
systems because I think he literally
thinks or believes that if we save the
humanities that's step one and then step
two is saving the world without
reflecting on all the reasons that the
humanities are the way they are which
has nothing to do with good theory or
bad Theory it's just you know the way
that the the system has been set up this
the system's internal logic pushes it
towards these things not because people
read too much bodard because no one has
read enough
bodard oh they need to read more bodard
bod the Fatal strategy is just to like
this this history has already ended
would be something that he'd say it's
already ended and we're just watching it
Peter out not try to like resurrect a
movement where it's us against the world
which sounds super culty and
metamodernism does have a super culty
Vibe for that it for that reason and it
appeals to 20-year-olds for that reason
I even I even heard some like uh
theories from a couple of friends of
mine that the other guys that wrote a
book about M metamodernism the one that
created a sanism they were actually
funded by these open society and Atlas
Foundation like it it it's very oh is it
a scop yeah yeah it seems like it is a
scop like I was really into this like a
couple of years ago when I read this
book and and these friends of mine they
told me like these guys they were
probably a scup they got this like super
fancy expensive get togethers in Sweden
where they would like retreat into the
mountains and speak about the future of
theory and everything was funded by
super high roller billionaires from
around the world it was very strange but
then it connects really well to the fact
fact like like like Eric was saying this
is the idealist left you know like this
is the idealist the idealist left like
they're trying to find back spirituality
it's just like a new religion like they
need another meta narrative to justify
the positions they're taking and these
books provides with ambiguous enough
terminology and vague enough stman
places to attack in order for them to to
to to posture against something that
doesn't necessarily exist and is
misrepresented constantly throughout the
book and and I think it makes perfect
sense with the idealist left it it it
fits super well with the Academia then
you can you know you can get lost within
those terminologies that nobody can
Define and and do nothing about the
world and just publish papers and ask
for more grants yeah yeah at risk at
risk of being uh are at risk of AD
homing which it is I wonder if there's a
reason that this came out of religious
studies religious studies first yeah
well the other video that I watched by
the uh the Dutch not the Dutch ones the
uh the Nordic the Nordic ones the uh the
the the
the I think one of those groups actually
tried to recruit me when I started
getting followers on YouTube oh [__] I'm
jealous yeah they they said I was
watching the one guy explaining it and
he was saying that well his interest in
metamodernism came kind of out of his
disillusionment with with integralism
like the the Ken again the Ken Wilbur
stuff and how there was a conference can
you explain what that is I don't know
what that is integralism is is yeah it's
based around this this again very
prolific very syncretistic writer named
Ken Wilbur who came up with that you
know there's some sort of that four
square all all quadrants all levels I
would just say Wikipedia because I he's
he's again he's trying to do a
syncretistic kind of philosophical
hodgepodge where he's making the he's
building the system of philosophy for of
the future kind of thing which is kind
of the vibe you get from this book but
it's a little more political and and
institutionally focused here whereas
like the Ken Wilbur stuff is a lot like
this but it's much more sort of broadly
aimed more broadly spiritually sprinkled
with Buddhist and Eastern religious
stuff and um you know same kind of
flavor of of appealing to a kind of
in the spiritual side right we have
institutional religions maybe we don't
really like those we have the sort of
institutionally adjacent religions like
protestantism and and and those sorts of
things and maybe we don't really like
those either so here's the spiritualist
element but they said he was saying that
even in the Ken Wilbur in integralism
stuff there was a conference several
years ago you know then there's a big
falling out after and even it was found
that that a cult had sort of developed
Ved amidst the members and it and it
harmed a lot of people and almost like a
almost like an intellectual little minis
Scientology thing going on and it was a
cult and not the whole thing I don't
want to say the whole [__] thing was
a cult what is integralism do you mind
Lum like giving like a vague definition
of what is
integralism God it's it's a system to
solve all the problems kind of like this
it's it's that's what I was trying to
compare it to this because it's very
it's it's an early version of
metamodernism it's an earlier version of
kind of
using like a syncretistic kind of
religious point of view so you learn a
bit you you spend a few years learning
about say Zen Buddhism and Daoism and
then you turn your sites back to like
Western science and you try to look at
like you
know what kinds of things are Western
scientists saying but they're just kind
of avoiding talking about the spiritual
aspect or what this might right I'm just
I'm I'm really just [__] I would just
look it up on Wikipedia look up
integralism look up Ken Wilbur
especially look up uh look up the uh
Institute for integralist and studies in
California because that's that I think
that's a a a great manifestation of
integralism but it's basically you know
a syncretistic philosophy that wants to
put
together you know everything and fit
everything together right it's a system
it's a system building kind of
Enterprise and and it's but it's built
on the backs of a kind of like movement
like this as well it wants to get people
interested it wants to get people
talking it wants to have events it wants
to be um outside of Academia because
academics kind of abuse them and treat
them poorly like they did the
speculative realists when that hit the
scene sorry I can't do much of a better
job than that but you know this is a
kind of continuation of that and those
and the Nordic people actually kind of
have a direct inspiration from that
stuff which I'm saying there's a
continuity of this kind of Desiring for
spiritualism that this feeds that's the
pathology I was trying to point out this
is this is taking advantage of 21st
century kind of Zoomers and Millennials
who young
Millennials who who want something more
in their lives and and it's got the
trappings of intellectual learning and
and and it's great that way I mean
that's not not a very positive
assessment but that's what I think it
kind of comes out as yeah there's a
market I'm sure and they need Buy in I'm
not buying it and I don't like bringing
up bad work just a [__] on it because
that's a waste of time but like I said
to kick this off if you're claiming that
you've invented the wheel
then I'm going to hold your your wheel
to a higher standard of rigor than if I
were to just read something that wasn't
so self grandis or wasn't so quick sodic
so there are good points in this book to
be sure I didn't bring any of them up
but especially hearing about the other
metamodernist sects I think I see what's
going on here it's join the crew come to
the parties Haw our philosophy is the
only one you'll ever need and then you
have a vague shadowy enemy Army that's
trying to undermine you when you
criticize or when they criticize your
book and then you can accuse them of
simping for the routinized postmodern
human Sciences or whatever they fight
with each other too the the Nordic guy
said that um the other metam modernists
hate him but he likes
them uh they're very
territorial we we should write a book we
should write a book oversimplifying the
metamodernist position and just like
putting them all into the same
bulk yeah post post metamodernism yeah
what will be next what will come after
metamodernism just for the sake of like
you know this like dial dialectic of
meaningless marketing
titles oh there can't be anything after
this we thought there couldn't be
anything after postmodernism but there
cannot be anything after and quote uh as
a goal for the human Sciences negating
the negative ethic this is the end of
History finally we got there yeah this
is this is the end of History bodard
predicted this I want to say in like
1988 or so when he just said like it's
over already we just haven't realized it
but we're still going to have the
simulation of everything we're going to
have the simulation of intellectual
debate we're going to have the
simulation of movements simulation of
religion which I think points to what
you're saying like you're not going to
have any real religion it's just going
to
ideology the religion without the
religion at the middle without the
actual belief it's pretended secularized
religion and and and who the [__] ever
needs Originals anyway like nobody
[__] cares about
Originals yeah we lost touch with those
a while ago yeah originals are p a we
want copies if if there's not something
else that it's a copy of then I don't
give a [__] about it yeah can I guy just
just enjoy dressing up as can for
Halloween and that's it I just want a
simple life you dressed up as Ken that's
awesome you didn't see the picture I did
but the listeners don't know that I saw
the picture oh yeah true so my wife my
wife Al Acadian psychoanalysis dressed
up as Barbie and I dressed up as Ken it
was very very fun we were super plastic
it was
fantastic that's that sounds
familiar oh I would like I'd like to see
that I am slightly aroused I must
say revolutionary happiness said says
quote that if you want to live a life
worth
having live a life worth having lived he
says and if you can recognize that
others want to do the same this will
transform your view of not only your
personal habits but the whole scholarly
Enterprise liberal [__] we just end
with some lib [__] I was just going to
say yeah liberal [__] to to to tie
the the the [__] ribbon on top of it
there are pluralistic ways in which one
might conceive udonia that's a nice oh I
haven't heard that one for a bit
Aristotle
udonia uh but I argued for engaged
compassion as the central virtue so I
mean it it sounds very humanistic sounds
like yeah liberal humanism you guys
nailed it it it's kind of not really
engaging with the post-humanist side of
postmodernism which again just points to
how kind of silly it is to set your
sights against something called quote
unquote
postmodernism look I'll be a
postmodernist as long as as long as you
need one
everyone but uh it's this is why it's
just a nonsense it's it was a nonsense
term to start with it was the
generalization and at least as a
generalization it should never be used
in the premise of an argument if you
want the argument to be serious it seems
like it is like leotard came up with the
term to try and describe something that
had already happened or something that
he felt like was well underway in this
transformation of knowledge because of
the economy and Science and Technology
and all the things he brings up and the
nature of knowledge is now changed it
takes such a long time for these terms
to actually make sense like like very
very haggled in the sense of the owl of
minurva like how the [__] can you like
give a to to a movement that is
according to him emerging like we we can
say the seed of postmodernism was in N
and like how long does it take for
somebody to name it like how can you say
metamodernism is a thing we haven't even
got a fix on what postmodernism is yeah
yes this is this is why I called it a
pathology because naming the thing
almost makes it worth engaging or makes
it real so if you name it before you
even do any of it then you're just a
step ahead of the game yeah you expect
the master signifier to do world the
heavy lifting it's like a reflection of
capitalism as as maybe the marxists
would say the kind of yeah this is the
other thing that there was the thing
that was bothering me D during the whole
book like these guys on purpose avoid
the effect on Capital on what they are
researching and what they're not
researching and like they they uh they
overemphasize underdetermined aspects of
the of how Academia is shaped but they
completely avoid the overdetermining
factors of how Academia
shaped yeah the university is a
neoliberal institution they got their
funding grants they got their CEOs they
got their Board of shareholders like as
if this is something we could all just
get together and agree to change to be
the central message of lumen is that
like Society develop like even Marx
right it develops behind our backs we
don't have control over it in fact we
don't even understand it until many many
years later or even just like look at
the of Benjamin's you know essay on the
technological reproducibility of art
right you it takes a long time for
conceptual apparatuses to catch up with
actual social change that has been going
on in the past 100 years so you know
unfortunately the super structure tends
to lag very far behind the
infrastructure and and it takes a while
to grasp these things fully yeah you
know yeah the goal of philosophy is to
grasp its own [__] moment which is
very hard so you think it's a mistake
for me after reading this book to try to
watch Netflix with my plans and expect
to have like a biosemiotics point of
view of Netflix it's a mistake then no
no that's a multispecies ethnography
that's good do it I was expecting my
Cactus to to to speak to me in Sign
Language via his Pines and propose to me
some new master categories for the
future yeah well if one of your plants
dies while you're watching binging
Ancient Aliens on Netflix then uh then
that's probably a good sign never more
my friend never more yeah if you're PL
your little Cactus growing up in the
desert of the real instead of the real
desert yeah all right well uh I'm sorry
I'm sorry if we burst at anyone's bubble
I'm sure there's going to be a bunch of
zealots that come in here and do
whatever zealots do but uh yeah we don't
have a cult that you can join and we
don't have a program for the future we
have nothing to offer we bring nothing
to the table how do you feel about that
yeah well we do have a we do have a
patreon you join you can join that I
have like a few quotes I like from some
books just DM me I'll send you my
favorite quotes what I think what I
think is really cool about this
conversation like my overall impression
is that this is Jordan Peterson for the
for the for the snobbish intellectual
left idealistically
speaking in some ways yeah I think it's
for lapsed Christians really well yeah
that also a very very strong point which
I agree like people are like they're
desperate for new religion I have a
friend in in in Argentina in Argentina
is like this very uh interesting place
at the moment because of the current
elections and the guy that is leading
the polls which is a [__] nightmare I
don't know if you heard him like Javier
mle but it's weird that um a lot of
people are really saying that we need a
new religion you know like we need even
if they're fake we need a new set of of
moral values that we can strive for and
keep us together because we're falling
apart as Society people much rather just
like go back I don't really care invent
something new even if it's fake and
let's all adhere to it which is going to
be better than this abstract nism of the
post like know late
capitalism yeah I think I think if I if
this had been written in a Manifesto
style which is a distinct literary style
if it's like this is a Manifesto for
metamodernism I wouldn't have been
nearly so hard on it but because it
sacrifices all intell ual rigor because
it just uses passive voice half the time
because it doesn't even identify the
enemies or site them just declares that
they exist and are everywhere then I'm
going to be harder on it but if it was a
Manifesto for metamodernism it would
have the same effect and I wouldn't be
able to criticize it because it would be
a different literary style I agree yeah
I I think it is that's what I was trying
to say is it does very much appeal to a
kind of religious impulse and I'm
surprised this didn't start in the
States because that seems to be where
that stuff comes from most often but
yeah California always yeah like you
know want some more meaning in my life
want to have conversations about you
know spiritual
matters if you if you look at the
functional purposes of religion it's not
it's not just belief that's kind of what
it's been reduced to but these other
things that you said these groups are
offering like Community Values um and
enemy H come on enemy yeah rituals
rituals anyway why don't we put a pin in
it uh Diego thanks thanks so much for
the reading it was the most energized I
got from a reading in a while although
maybe for the wrong reasons yeah I I
don't even remember like when was the Le
told you I I remember recommending this
book to you like a couple of times but
in a very long period of time pills like
this is not recent I I know I know
you're like a Hermit in in in Reading
your messages and your DMs like we we
normally have this couple of months lag
between your response and my reply I
apologize no no no that's okay I I mean
I'm I'm the one that is addicted to
social media I'm glad that people can
actually avoid them but I I don't
remember when it was the last time I
recommended this book to you like what
six months ago it was during the summer
because after you recommended it I
actually read it in the summer and I
like I said I got to page 11 and I was
like [__] this I don't want to hurt
Diego's feelings but this is dog [__] no
at it too yeah you're right you did
recommend it a while back and then we
looked at it and we and and pills
actually just zoned in exactly on the
critique that I would make overall is
that like like read the opening it's so
ambitious like it's so like the claims
it makes are so
likeo yeah I think if if actually you
know and he said he's going to write he
said he's going to write more books on
the different and expand the various
sections of this yeah but I would
recommend that he maybe tone down those
initial claims or maybe change the
literary style like like like Bill said
or maybe he's going to put a SoCal on us
and we are all going to be fools when he
reveals himself as another Alan soal
yeah we published an episode on his on
his fake Trojan Horse leftist Theory
that's that'll be I'll be really mad if
he does that in any case the the cart is
about a mile before the horse in this
case so and I don't discourage people
from you know trying ambitious things
but if you're going to try something do
it right don't don't do this anyway
let's put a pin in that uh Diego thanks
so much for coming back always a
pleasure send my requests to vict and
and say his lip takes on on gas are
horrible yeah thank you for that
stimulating read and thank you for the
image of uh you and your wife dressed as
Ken and Barbie yeah I will share you can
use it as a thumbnail if you've got any
pictures uh send them my way
e if we look at Edgar Allen Poe uh we'll
send you an invite for that too awesome
yeah and we might have to do a news
episode since this uh genocide is going
to take what they said like now 10 years
probably yeah I don't I don't know like
it well you never know but it may scale
like like pretty pretty quickly in the
next few weeks there's a big
announcement from hezb tomorrow so let's
see how it goes all right put a pin in
it until then thanks listeners check out
democracy now tomorrow and and scene
signing out
[Music]
cut